i've heard a rumor that you uh you love
british food i love british food too
that's crazy i think jellied eel is
probably on the west side of sussex
probably my favorite yeah no one eats
jelly deal you know that yeah yeah they
do i saw it on food youtube channels one
with the gravy and the pie did you try
it with the you don't like
like my taste buds must be fun yeah god
i love how there's like so many like
foods that it's like this this food is
here because of like in the war time
like we can't eat real meat and it's
like [ __ ] not in the war now eat real
food
most british stuff has some kind of
origin yeah we were desperate so we made
this thing yeah yeah yeah yeah and then
it stayed around for some reason i love
beans and toasts though i've said this
on the episode with lily but i actually
[ __ ] love beans
it's good
i'll make it for you soggy that's good
okay listen you have toast right nice
like thick bread oh i know what it is
no one actually just eats beans and only
toast you put like cheese you put like a
fried egg on it and then you put like
some sauce oh
it's so good
this is good wait what are you eating
what are you doing do you like beans in
general uh i like regrets
do you like beans i'm i'm okay as a side
as a side okay so that's the funny thing
in the uk i cannot like stress how often
beans are eaten like it's very often
it's like every side it goes with like
pretty much every british cuisine every
restaurant will have beans on the side
yeah somewhere yeah for no
not really mine you don't want to come
to the uk
no
no i don't think so for like it's like
anything really are you this i don't
know it's kind of how do you think about
how do you feel about um ireland
fun i love [ __ ] love ireland yeah i
[ __ ] love island it's like
it's it's like up there with japan for
like one of the most aesthetic countries
i've ever been to because like in japan
you go anywhere and it's like you take a
picture and it's like [ __ ] instagram
worthy it's the same thing in ireland
you could just drive around so green
yeah he's never been to wales that's why
yeah wales is the same was this yeah
yeah yeah i'm from wales yeah do you
know where wales is
yeah welshman yeah that's it that's it
because
some people think it's like a [ __ ]
city in england or something no i know
it's a country okay i mean that's more
than most yeah yeah have you been to
wales no i've never been here i've never
been in europe why do you know why do
more people not talk about whales
they're terrible at branding is is is
there tourism like just just [ __ ]
because they're [ __ ] at branding they
had guinness and then they were like if
you want to get drunk come here yeah
because
they're well off there i've heard the
same thing about scotland as well where
scotland's like a beautiful [ __ ]
country you've got the whiskey there as
well what does wells have sheep lots and
lots of sheep so is new zealand yeah but
like it's louisiana's too far like
who the [ __ ] wants to go to new zealand
i want to go to new zealand yeah because
you're australian it's like what like a
like a like a car just closed it's still
four hours from now on
it's still [ __ ] far away but it's
beautiful oh uk's nice but i feel like
if you don't drink it's kind of boring
yeah yeah so that's a see that's a red
flag is the thing if you need to be
drunk to enjoy something then you don't
actually know what no no no no no no no
no no being drunk it's about like
everything is designed around you do it
with a drink yeah it's not so you get
drunk it's like okay you wanna do dance
where you gotta drink replay yeah it's
probably dart sober yeah yeah like every
every activity you do there is paired
with drinking yeah yeah in some way
shape or form i i see the denial
i understand it's emblematic of a larger
issue
well what if you go round one with
drinks in those drink holders i mean i
like that yeah
that's how you would enhance it your
justification for a country yeah
okay
the british the british philosophy is
every activity can be made more fun
right right yeah see america is in its
infancy right it's still like what 200
something years old
yeah so they haven't got like the
depression age yet where they realize
just [ __ ] give up let's just drink it
yeah i'm telling you i'm getting there
so the uk's just been like oh [ __ ] man
yeah
this church has been here for like 900
years may's all [ __ ] drinking it yeah
i don't know
father may i yeah i'm pretty sure that's
why you know religion like christianity
did so well because the wine i'm pretty
like if that wasn't in it yeah you think
you think british people would like take
on that you're going to [ __ ] sunday
mass and being like yo let me nick this
like when they leave sunday
like down at the pub people like so like
people just go to the pub like elderly
people over the age of like 50 yeah from
like 12 o'clock and they just start
drinking 12 o'clock is uh a bit late oh
yeah yeah i've heard from sydney when
she because uh my wife worked at like a
british pub and before the pub opened
there would be like old guys waiting
queueing to get in this pub at like 8
a.m oh my gosh and they'd order like a
double whiskey on the rocks when they
come in that's kind of cool that's kind
of cool
i want to be there
what are you doing today bob
nothing else just pub that's what they
do because that's where you see your
friends in the uk when you're like that
old yeah yeah yeah but like i've i've
seen some people just sitting there at
the pub on their own oh yeah as well so
they're not even going to the pub to
like convert what's aussie culture like
pretty much the same
so except no except for us it's if if
the if it's too early to go to the pub
you just go to the beach yeah yeah
you're drinking at the beach or
something drinking the beach is the
[ __ ] best except you can't do it in a
lot of beaches in australia so never
mind that
hawaii
yeah oh yeah i feel like they would have
been like super strict yeah i don't know
i've never gotten in trouble
that went from so confident
with a friend for dinner and a lunch so
no breakfast even breakfast like 11.
one of the meals
very early because this guy came in
ordered three beers drank them all on
his own then just left and i was like i
was like what are you he's getting the
day started yeah yeah he like dropped
his kids off somewhere
finally
i can just leave it is very like
depressing
yeah yeah that's i think that's why we
are
the way we are
that's why everyone is cynical and you
know just miserable but it's like a fun
charming way yeah
we're very self-deprecating yeah yeah
yeah if you guys want to go get thai
food here rune pear oh yeah i'm
delicious my friend uh
he's also thai he was over for a while
dude he would make like he would he was
just making us food because we gave him
free house yeah yeah yeah so [ __ ]
good
i'm like because i'm like so judgmental
when it comes to thai food because like
my mom was like run around like a thai
restaurant so i'm like
it's kind of like gordon ramsay you know
where where i'm just like you know the
peak yeah
this is the kind of place that didn't
take like a didn't know what a credit
card was until like a year ago okay
that's that's good
that's how that's up because like when i
go to a thai place and it looks [ __ ]
bougie as [ __ ] i'm like this is not
official
now this place has everything it's got
the dying fish in the aquarium in the
front it's got the task to take cash the
money laundering in the back it's good
it's really good it's called the rune
parrots and like right over the hill
food as well like if it doesn't make me
a little uncomfortable to be then it
will not be good yeah yeah yeah the same
one in japan like i don't know how they
got the vibe down like we we found this
really good indian restaurant and it is
literally just like copy and paste the
exact same thing you'd get here where
you walk in it's like unapologetically
like kind of like epic really bad decor
yeah the menu is like
like the pictures they took looked like
a crime scene it's like they threw the
food on the table and they're like look
at the picture yeah it's like it's like
like what the [ __ ] is this but then
you're like you're like okay you try and
you're like this is the best [ __ ]
yeah i've ever had it's so good
same thing like chinese restaurants
right if you go to a chinese restaurant
and there's not some some person with
like like an earpiece like shouting out
orders in chinese when you when you
order in the background you feel
uncomfortable yeah like you're like can
i
what the [ __ ]
yeah
and then they always have to shout back
from the kitchen yeah yeah yeah you know
it's like this is gonna be sick just
aggression yeah
it's very aggressive yeah anger yeah
it's like the authentic japanese like if
you go like abroad right what's
it's run by a bunch of white people it's
probably not going to be good
yeah well i mean that's that's true
the first thing i think of the first
thing i see or try to find i'm like is
there a single japanese person working
in this place yeah yeah like in the
kitchen is there is there at least a
japanese girl in the kitchen if yes i
have my hopes up well a lot of the
japanese restaurants are in america and
the uk are often run by chinese people
yeah yeah just like oh well you guys
don't know the difference yeah exactly
exactly and honestly they don't know the
difference a lot of the times yeah we
went to a a place yesterday and now i
don't trust google reviews in this in
the city you can't it was like 4.5 and
it was an italian 4.5 means garbage
okay okay you need to take what the [ __ ]
what four by five means every mcdonald's
is four point five oh cause in japan if
if it's 4.5 it's like it must have like
served god yeah yeah yeah
everything is below like four yeah like
you're looking for a four seven four
eight yeah oh my [ __ ] yeah
yeah in japan everything's like 3.5
average and that's still a really good
[ __ ] meal toxicity place that's like
a crime people people in japan like they
complain at anything yeah on the review
not a person
you should when you go have a quick read
of the google reviews it's really
bizarre seeing what they nitpick it's
really pedantic yeah really really odd
like they'll be like they didn't hand me
the menu fast enough it's really weird
so we went to this italian place and i
knew it was like oh we walked in and it
was all uh like there was not a white
person in the restaurant and i was like
okay i mean i'm not saying you can't do
it but you're like
i'm sure there's no shortage of italians
like in america america i was like oh no
oh no that uh he ordered lasagna it was
cold
i got microwave lasagna unfortunately i
took a bite of that i didn't know you
could make a lasagna with zero flavor
yeah yeah like i actually couldn't taste
it yeah it's just like there was like a
baseball game going on there's no news
yeah those are the words just like it's
new american food
what are you who are you appealing to
here like the guy who comes after work
and is like i love italian food i want a
microwave lasagna yeah man but it's
weird quite because uh l.a especially
has like a really really good [ __ ]
food scene because it's really
competitive over here yeah they got some
oh it's the one saving grace of this
[ __ ] of the city it's so good like
if i'm like oh i want korean food i live
in korea town if i want
uh like tacos i just go down the street
and there's a taco truck every 10 feet
yeah yeah it's nice it's really good i
love i love mexican food it's so [ __ ]
up
street vendor they're probably good yeah
so they might give you food poisoning
they give me food poisoning i still eat
them
it's just that i still come back that's
just the spice that comes with it you
know
because like yeah when i come to la
every time there's two things i look
forward to it's like mexican food and
korean barbecue i [ __ ] [ __ ] love
korean barbecue so much yeah have you
ever been to korea i've not no no i
actually like i've been to korea once
and i don't know like i'm not going to
speak for every korean barbecue but like
i preferred my because i went to ukraine
barbecue almost every day in korea yeah
and i actually preferred the korean
barbecue i found in l.a i have heard
that that's like it's very similar if
not
like better yeah
because
la or just america is all about
indulgence right so you can really
indulge yourself with like the meats
here yeah and it just feels [ __ ] good
man you like you go to a korean bbq in
l.a you're you're guaranteed to get a
food coma afterwards right yeah and
that's like that's that's that's the
feeling i want from a korean barbecue
yeah and i think like the meat quality
here is really good like especially the
beef and everything like that so
yeah like i'm not like
a lot of asian countries import their uh
beef stuff from other countries yes oh
yeah so like i know japan often japan
yeah most of their beef from america
yeah yeah yeah well like japan has like
wagyu beef and everything but i feel
like after living
yeah that's also like sometimes i don't
even count that as beef it's so fatty
it's so buttery that it just sometimes
i've had wagyu where it's like
overwhelmingly buttery to the point
where it's gross again yeah yeah yeah
because like living in japan wagyu is so
easy to get your hands on that's going
to be every day i mean yeah
they sell it in supermarkets yeah and
then you have it once and you're like
this is [ __ ] amazing and then the
tenth time you have it you just really
really that's just really rich it's a
really really one bite and you're like
oh i just kind of want like immediately
i actually prefer normal steaks over
wagyu now after like living it makes
sense yeah yeah you have it too much
it's it's kind of [ __ ] yeah it's a
really nice like for a one time thing
which is like which is like the
experience here you you yeah yeah
exactly you have one wagyu you have one
bite and it's a [ __ ] amazing bite
yeah but you can buy like steaks of
wagyu in japan and that's like that's
like too much yeah that's too much fun
don't let the cow come for two weeks
right before the slaughter did you know
oh my god you did it off to the wagyu
pile yeah
[Applause]